[Musique]
il était une fois l'histoire des comptes
des personnages que l'on connaît tous
plongés dans l'univers de noël d'hier et
d'aujourd'hui avec les classiques du
moment est la meilleure amie va partir à
sa recherche et le petit poucet sème des
cailloux dans une forêt enchantée et
alice a quitté le pays des merveilles
pour celui de noël
il n'a pas trop que je connais mais
c'est lui là je connais c'est quoi alice
au pays des merveilles
tu l'as lu
non je connus quand même dans le château
le parcours continue
et la belle est endormi dans une chambre
ambiance noël toujours un conte qui fait
rêver les plus petits piqué par la
sorcière et après ses belles et bahreïn
et dans lequel il éprouve et baby l'a
fait réveiller ya peu et basse et grecs
sur marié raconte des histoires tous les
soirs c'est pourtant un stage à plus
loin il y a les personnages que les
petits reconnaissent et puis il ya les
autres qui connaît l'histoire du chat
botté la vase y raconte moi ils vont
rater plus et les parents eux aussi
retombe en enfance cdi compte
voilà qui nous ont fait rêver la petite
sirène des nouveaux ça nous fait revivre
des moments en fait des souvenirs de
lecture c'était c'est vraiment bien
puis à la fin du parcours surprise en
fait par noël tu seras d'ici lundi
d'ici là trois à compter de mai